Philippo là président des patriotes vous
avez pris des petites notesi comment ça
va vous bah ça Vaz en forme vous bonne
année ouais bah bonne année pu unu
détente sur PL vous êtes
détenduoui'estce qu'il a fait là pour
jour de long moi ouais bah un truc sympa
avec des amis tranquille quoi tranquille
alors hier vous avez vu Géraldine maill
pardon vous avez vu geréraldine j'ai vu
les extraits en tout
cas oui quand même quand même alors
qu'est-ce que vous dites
mais je trouve ça d'abord ce serait bien
que vous excusiez plutôt que d'essayer
de vous raccrocher au branche par vousz
vous excuser vous avez pas vu l'émission
dont on parle non non c'est une c'est
une c'est une accusation moins grave que
celle que je vous fais vous vous avez
accusé moi je traité de pauvre idiot
déjà des gens qui euh ont manifesté pour
leurs droit pour la liberté certains
pour juste leur boulot he je vous
rappelle qu'il y a eu des infirmières
des pompiers des gens qui vous soignent
qui ont pas eu de boulot et de
rémunération pendant des mois et des
mois moi j'ai fait 100 manifestations
j'en ai organisé 100 au niveau
nationalis pour les libertés antipass
contre le confinement contre et cetera
et pour les suspendus et aujourd'hui
pour la vérité sur les effets
secondaires parce que ça c'est le grand
débat et vous pourrez pas non plus y
échapper et c'est aussi vis-à-vis de ces
gens-là qu'il va falloir vous présen va
falloir vous présenter vos excuses aussi
aux victimes aujourd'hui qui peuvent
plus marcher qui sont pour certaines
malheureusement parties décédé d'AVC de
crise cardiaque et ca de cancer
fulgurant et et et non ces
manifestations étaient très belle très
belle parce qu'il y avait ce qu'il a
plus beau dans l'humanité c'estd la
défense de valeur très chè comme la
santé la liberté l'humanité le refus
d'apparte comme le Pass parce que le
Pass vous vendrez pas vous vendrez
pas mm on a pu sur un petit bouton et on
a des buons qui sort quoi
arrêou an
sont parler là de sur ce plateau et
ailleurs pendant des mois vous avez
raconté n'importe quoi vous m'avez
traité moi et d'autres de tous les noms
parce qu'on expliquit que ça n'empêchait
pas la contamination la transmission
vous nous expliquez monsieur nollo je me
souens de débat enflammé ici vous me
disiez la Suède c'est l'apocalypse parce
qu'ils ne font pas le Pass la
suèdeoup maintenant ça vous dérange à
l'époque vous aimez bien à l'époque vous
étiez ravi de parler de la Suède parce
que vous me disiez comme ils ne font pas
le masque obligatoire ils font pas le
passe il font pas le la suè justement
alors vousz app la Suède comment elle va
la
Suède mais sache qu'ils ont fait
leireour vous essayz l'umour c'est raté
je vous
ass pas mal pas par sera enc
plus demande à ce que vos équipes cherch
vous allez voir le pas sanitaire a été
en urgence rétabli en Suède su
il y a pas eu de passe en
Suède pas on va regarder mon
av est-ce que je peux vous envoyer
l'article en tout cas à l'époque vous me
dis ça va être l'ocalyse aujourd'hui eu
qui
on moi j'ai envie dire une deè chose
vousvez parce tout ça c'est lire c'est
lunaire je crois que vous faites ces
accusations là maintenant parce que
c'est maintenant que sortent toutes les
vérités sur les victimes les effets
secondaires vous avez des commissions
d'enquête aux États-Unis monsieur fa
aussi qui a été mis sur le grille au
Congrès américain commission d'quète
royaumuni des procès au danemar au
Danemark ils ont payé 1 million et dei
d'euros d'amende parce qu'il y a une
infirmière 31 ans qui s'est retrouvé 90
% en incapacité après sa 3è dose et en
France évidemment c'est à chap de on
essaie de rediaboliser les gens je ne
suis pas DUP de tout cela je pense que
moment où il y a encore ce matin des
meting ou un débat
par au nombre de cas en Europe la
suèdeés instaurer un pass vaccinal
monsieur Philippo il va falloir bosser
quand
mêmerou
dansement prenez un extrait d'un truc
faut regarder les conditions et jerouve
dans un instant
avec rentrer dans la suite alors j'ai un
truc toute l'Europe point eu qui veut
dire
Europe Slovaquie pas de passe Slovénie
pas de passe Suède pas de passe Suisse
pas de passe en Suède il y a eu un pass
ation
an vousz dit
[Rires]
pas il me dit des contevérités non mais
il me dit des contevérités il n j moi je
vais vous dire autre chose ce débat est
lunaire ce débat est lunaire parce que
oui les gens qui sont venus parler sont
des gens parfaitement respectables je
les défendrai jusqu'au bout et ils
défendent des valeurs tous beaucoup mais
pas tous oui bien sûr bien sûr sur sur
des centaines de manif évidemment on pe
avoir un individu là et cetera bah oui
et peut-être que dans cette salle il y a
aussi une personne qui est pas terrible
ça peut arriver vous savez ça pas dire
que ça dénigre tout le public de TPMP
voyez ce que je veux direêre une
subtilité qui vous éch euh pour le reste
c'est marrant cette accusation au moment
d'ailleurs je le disais il y a tous les
le débat sur les effets secondaires qui
vous dérange énormément qui est en train
de d'exploser mais surtout moi je
regarde les paysans allemands là en ce
moment qui manifestent contre l'Union
européenne et je les soutiens à fond
vous savez ce que dit le gouvernement et
les médias les grands médias allemand il
disent ce sont des racistes et des
antisémites ce sont des complotistes les
gilets jaunes qu'est-ce qu'on disait ce
sont des extrémistes et des antisémite
Trump qu'est-ce qu'on dit qu' a gagné la
première primaire dans l'OA là
incroyable R que que dit Biden ça et les
grands médias CNN tout ça ils disent
quoi ils disent c'est Hitler c'est les
nazis au bout d'un moment va falloir
arrêter cet argument extrêmement
problématique d'abord parce que vous
vous affadissez ce qui est vraiment
l'antisémitisme ou l'hitlerisme et
deuxièmement va falloir bosser un petit
peu sur le fond vous NZ rien à
dire questionsur on est pas sur les
questions les gars parce que y c'est
parce fait je savoir qui est Monsieur
PhIP j'eni pas j'en a même pas ne dites
pas qui c'est antisémite madame non qui
est j'ai dit question non qui monsieur
Philippo en fait je voulais savoir parce
qu'en en mars 2020 vous étiez pour un
confinement général et vous étiez pour
le port du masque même à l'extérieur
pourquoi vous avez changé tu peux juste
finir ta question par y a que les
imbéciles qui changent pas la vie madame
c'est pour ça mais moi je crois que
c'est du du de l'opportunisme politique
en fait vous avez vu qu'il y avait
personne en politique là-dessus et vous
êtes avec un relatif échec puisque vous
avez rien eu il y avait personne qui a
voté POUR VOUS nulle part dans aucune
élection mais pourquoi en fait vous avez
pris C décision trompz-vous j'ai fait 7
% en régional un parti qui est tout
nouveau qui même assez confidentiel non
non c'est pas confidentiel 7 % vous AZ
même pas pour l'élection présidentielle
ah oui mais ça madame si vous pointez du
doigt le problème si vous pointez du
Doig le problème démocratique des
parages on pourra faire unem vous étiez
visionnaire tout le monde aurait voté
pour vous si vous aviez vraiment la
vérité alors là vous me dites il faut
faire l'électoralisme bah non désolé je
défends mes convictions pendant 3
semaines non non mais c'est intéressant
pendant 3 semaines effectivement je me
suis dit il ils nous ont dit que cétait
terrible la Chine l'Italie la France on
va essayer de leur faire confiance au
bout de 3 semaines j'ai compris
l'arnaque madame en mars fin mars avril
début 2020 j'ai compris l'arnaque et
j'ai changé d'avis évidemment et je n'ai
jamais changé d'avis derre oui parce que
moi je change la vie en fonction des
fait c'est par exemple quand j'ai vu je
suis pas antivaccin à la base moi j'ai
fait des vaccins et cetera il y a pas de
problème et quand j'ai vu que ce
produitl ne fonctionnait pas cré des
effets
secondaires vin
maisomcise madame l'OMS nous disait
qu'on allait mourir de la variole du
singe il y a un an et demi que c'était
l'alerte rouge générale
d'acc
réér un truc à vos cheveux moi je pense
qu'il faut un
moment je dis juste au français qui nous
regardent l'accusation deotisme
extrémisme je t'ad j'aurais jamais d
dire de venir
défendre vé des millions de personnes
Ress dè qu' une cause sérieuse gilet
Jaun question j'ai une question poser
avant partiez par faut y aller est-ce
que vous avezage
brésilien je suis passé chez votre Coiff
avant
bravo pas s c'est pas
séux
Terri saué des millions de personnes et
a empêché une catastrophe planétaire ça
c'est la vérité la
vérit'av aucun risque avec le covid à se
faire injecter
le merci FL Philippo qui a bien merci
Béatrice mer merci bravo tu donneras
l'adresse de ton coiffeur tu peux le
mettre